the topic of transparency in government
is an important topic that's much bigger
than any one administration but it's
been a topic that Donald Trump has
pandered about for a very long time
Donald Trump promised that his
administration would be the most
transparent one of his advisers
Kellyanne Conway has been a sort of
regular fixture on television saying
that Donald Trump's administration is in
fact the most transparent and it's
obviously never been true and we have a
new example of this a couple of days ago
Donald Trump ended a requirement from
the Obama era where the government was
required to publish a yearly reports
with numbers of how many people were
killed in drone strikes and
counterterrorism operations not in war
zones where the United States is engaged
Donald Trump has revoked that
requirement via an executive order last
year the Trump administration simply
didn't publish it now they are ending
the requirement to do it and the reason
that we have this in the first place is
that under Barack Obama there were
complaints rightly so I was one of the
people complaining that his
administration was simply not bring
being transparent about drone strikes in
many countries countries like Pakistan
and Somalia but Libya Yemen so the Obama
administration put in this requirement
and that requirement has now been
cancelled by Donald Trump there are
really serious debates to be had about
the specifics of drone warfare there are
legal debates our drone strikes legal
are they sometimes legal or always legal
or never legal and if they are sometimes
legal when and under what circumstances
and what law governs them governs them
are they moral which is a whole other
can of worms that could be opened up
about drums drone strikes what is an
acceptable level if any I should say of
collateral damage as a result of drone
policy and is any level of that
collateral damage acceptable
are we in the net-net at the end of the
day killing more or fewer people because
the drone program
fists then if it didn't exist because
remember if we didn't have drones we
wouldn't necessarily be doing nothing
about some of those people were
targeting we might still be going after
them but in ways that could lead to more
people being killed that's an argument
that is sometimes made these are all
debates that we could have about drone
strikes and we should have about drone
strikes but how can we even have those
debates if the administration is hiding
even more numbers about drone strikes
around the world there is no national
security justification for cancelling
this reporting the information that was
being published was not nearly specific
enough that it would cause any kind of
security issues and before we get to the
bigger picture there's also an element
of hypocrisy here because under Barack
Obama Republicans pretended to care
about drone strikes they pretended to
care about the number they pretended to
care about the locations and the
legality and the tactics and the
strategy behind Barack Obama's use of
drone strikes
all of a sudden under Donald Trump it
doesn't matter anymore and they don't
even care if the transparency around the
number is eliminated by Donald Trump the
bigger picture issue as usual is Donald
Trump's transparency he promised to be
way more transparent than Barack Obama
he promised to be the most transparent
president in history his advisers have
claimed credit for him for being the
most transparent president in history
and the reality is that he's one of the
least transparent modern presidents
drone strikes which we just talked about
today tax returns every other candidate
and president dating back who knows how
many decades has released their tax
returns Donald Trump said he would maybe
in the future refused to do it
has not released his tax returns press
briefings under other administrations
they often would take place daily at
least weekly they would be at least
somewhat substantive they would have
some reasonable duration during which a
number of questions could be asked under
the Trump administration few and far
between even further and four
between overtime extraordinarily short
one time I think Sarah Huckabee Sanders
gave like a five minute press briefing
and of course riddled with lies and
distortions partially probably because
Sarah Huckabee Sanders doesn't even know
what Donald Trump's position is on many
issues partially because they are
obfuscating because so many issues are
just disadvantageous for them to talk
about and we actually have data around
this the sunlight foundation tracks
government transparency and
administration transparency and the
Trump administration is an absolute and
total joke and this is just more of the
same promises made and promises not kept
the transparency promises have been a
joke there was never even the mere
possibility that Donald Trump was going
to stick to it we talked on yesterday's
program about the promises that have
been made by Donald Trump on both two
types of deficits the federal budget
deficit and the national trade deficit
those promises have obviously not been
kept promises with regard to successes
that he would be having geopolitically
israeli-palestinian peace North Korea
etc etc etc promises made and promises
not kept the sort of the bigger picture
theme of this administration and then
when it comes to transparency it's huge
promises around transparency and a move
to be one of the least transparent
administrations in recent time this is
not praise of Barack Obama okay my my
criticisms of Barack Obama were
extensive and numerous they included
drone policy they included lack of
transparency they included a lot of the
handling and dealing with whistleblowers
this is not a Obama was great on this
issue thing and in fact the reason we
had this drone reporting requirement was
because of the lack of transparency that
people correctly assessed with Barack
Obama Trump is just even worse on this
issue
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I would love
to hear from you about this you can also
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show after the break we will go
to the phones many people wanting to
talk to me today and I will talk to some
of them next
one of today's sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below